there's a lot of people who've been
asking how the hell are bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies being used during the
russia ukraine conflict immediately
politicians in the united states and
many others start to jump to the fact
are russians going to use
cryptocurrencies to evade sanctions
instead what we've seen is that the
country of ukraine itself they posted on
twitter a link and they said hey give us
donations the crypto community has come
together and donated more than 100
million dollars to the government that
doesn't even include the donations that
went to ngos and other types of
government organizations
and so ultimately what we're watching is
that crypto is for everyone bitcoin is
being used by the good guys and
potentially the bad guys it's a neutral
technology but here's a heartwarming
story that i think you'll really enjoy
there's a ukrainian boy who escaped war
holding a usb stick that had 40 percent
of his life savings in cryptocurrency
ultimately what we have seen are
millions and millions and millions of
refugees who've had to escape the
country many of them leaving behind
their livelihoods their wealth and any
assets that they had to their name they
simply have the clothes on their back
and they're running to the border trying
to get out of the conflict zone bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies are here to help
these people they're bearer assets that
mean as long as you have that seed
phrase in your brain you can go anywhere
in the world and you have access to your
wealth bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are
literally saving the financial life of
millions of people right now and we're
watching it play out in the russia
ukraine conflict regardless of what you
think of the technology remember it's
neutral and the good people get to
benefit just as much as anyone else
that's good for bitcoin that's good for
these people and ultimately i think
we're going to continue to see more and
more people learn about these
technologies and put it to use in their
everyday life hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time